And then before we close out, let's look at some useful tips for getting started with
your project. So as we spoke about before, creating subscene tracks is going to be super
useful for working with multiple people on these shots and these sequences. So whether
you want to organize per department, maybe have character animation effects, lighting,
etc. You can essentially nest the storyboard sequences into a standard level sequence.
Then we can kind of go through the layering, almost like bread crumb in to get the functionality
quickly moving between the subscene tracks. So trying to open an sd storyboard sequence
will crash Unreal Engine. So that's also worth noting. So just check your current engine version.
This may not be the case, but just make sure you're saving your content as you go will
be something good to do moving forward. So the subscene tracks can then be expanded into
given sublayers. So you may have, as we said before, this character animation track, for
example, and then you may have sub sequences that are per character type, for example, you can get
as granular or as high level as you want. So we just want to consider subscene tracks for the
various elements. Just don't add subscenes for your storyboards. As we mentioned before,
that could cause some crashing for you. It's also worth noting that E-Post storyboard does
not support spawnable actors at this time. So if you see actors in your content browser or your
world outliner that are like this, they've not got the lightning icons, then that's what you want.
If you see any kind of cameras that are being spawned at runtime, which is what this lightning
icon means, then E-Post isn't going to be aware of them. So you just want to add all the actors
into your scene to be using with these sequences. And then maybe you want to set some useful hot
keys here. As you begin working with these tools more, you'll find your own workflow,
but here are a few to get you started. And then we've got a couple more here. So just a quick
note here, E-Post storyboarding requires the highlighted shortcut keys to be disabled or
remapped. As we said at the start, it may just cause some conflicts with the default functionality.
And then we've also got a couple more timeline tricks here. If you want to just get more familiar
with using a sequencer, and especially when you're editing a lot of shots, these kind of tools might
help on that journey. So there's a good white paper to read here, creating the Fortnite trailer. It
just helps you understand the virtual production process of how these cinematics are created.
And a few extra resources here for you to dig into, some getting started guides and some
documentation. And all this course today was credited by Kevin Miller, Brennan Carroll,
Elodie Moog, and Fabrice DeBarge. So thank you again for those.